[Music]
this
is star talk i'm your host neil degrasse
tyson
this episode i'm calling a physicist
reads the newspaper chuck
hey i'm not that physical you're not
that's okay
just in case anybody was wondering
in fact every comedy routine is really a
comedian reads the newspaper right
because you're typically there's a lot
of commenting on absolutely on
on current events yeah but so
this show was created because i saw this
product out there
this thing this interface that i just
said i
got to get the creator of that interface
on star talk
and that creator is a physicist an
old-time
friend and colleague max tegmark max
welcome back to star talk
thank you neil all right max is
professor of physics at mit
does a lot of different things with his
life he's got a couple of books out
there
uh he loves the subject of ai and
thinking deep thoughts about
the future of civilization and our
ability to be the
be good shepherds of the power we have
over ourselves
and what that means so max you've got
this thing i've been reading about
called improve the news this is very
ambitious of you and you did this like
what you did this you did this for your
summer covid vacation
oh my god so what is it wait a minute
is this a physicist's version of the
clay ashtray
that that you bring home from summer
camp yeah yeah
well the little macrame thing yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
what did max do for his summer vacation
and what does it have to do with the
news well it actually goes all the way
back to when they locked down mit in
march i just thought
i'm going to go stir crazy and i decided
to pick the
single thing i was most upset about and
just try to
do something a little bit useful about
it and that was this is march 2020 when
they closed down yes indeed not only
mit many other schools who were smart
closed down
right about right right there in march
okay yeah and i i i'm feeling as i'm
sure many of you who are listening to
this also feel that
our democracy hasn't been doing so great
recently
there are increasing signs of
polarization
and dysfunction and it's not just here
in america it's
happening a lot on the global scale also
and um
i think it's so easy to slip into this
over quick diagnosis and just say oh
it's because of
so and so it's their fault that's it you
know
i i think the root cause of this is a
lot deeper it actually has a lot to do
with um
with machine learning people have
stopped reading the newspaper on paper
very much
and most people get their news now from
social media
and so on and they are constantly being
manipulated by these
algorithms they're just trying to show
them whatever they're going to
click on the most to maximize the ad
revenue right and
and an unfortunate result of this i have
a lot of friends you know in the
companies that do this
who totally haven't seen it coming the
unfortunate result is that uh
just to be clear the companies that do
this that's euphemism
for facebook for twitter for instagram
that's that's euphemism oh for sure
google yeah yeah
so they want they've these algorithms
discovered that the best way to
keep people glued to their rectangles
is to show them things that elicit
strong feelings that piss them off for
example
it doesn't matter so much if it's true
or not as long as it has the effect of
gluing them to their screens and and
this is called trap people and these
so-called filter bubbles where they just
read more and more stuff that reinforces
whatever conceptions they had
and it's gotten to the point that
people with different views can't even
talk in civilized ways with each other
anymore and start to hate each other and
i just started to think hey
why is it that i never see
two science friends fight as bitterly
about the interpretation of quantum
mechanics as i see
people insulting each other across party
lines over politics
what is it that we do right in the
scientific truth seeking
that maybe we could share and
beam into the media landscape a little
bit you know the old the
that we have this pretty good scheme for
how to figure out what's true actually
and it's called science right so i
decided to code up
this uh tool which you mentioned here
and as a this is the university we did
it for
students for fun so it's free no ads
anything and it's been really fun
you know i love the idea of democracy
but for it to flourish people have to
have a good understanding of what's
actually happening in the world
right only then will they vote in their
self-interest and do
constructive things and i think i'm not
the only person who feels that
the overall quality of my news has been
going down so hey if we can improve it a
little bit
you know awesome so max i don't want to
interrupt but i
just got to ask you in in your
development of this
improve the news tool um did you factor
in
uh the fact that most americans are
stupid
i actually feel that this is shocking
not only
i'm just saying i'm just saying that
that's a factor
that is a factor i would say this is
propaganda
exactly the big companies that uh
that that's keeping running algorithms
that trap people into phase with the
burglars to just blame it on the
consumer
it's the same old trick that tobacco
companies used to use with
say oh it's not our fault that the
children start smoking cigarettes
they're just
stupid don't blame us right um
okay it's a way of shifting blame what's
actually happening of course is
we can only an ordinary american can
only
choose between the things they have
access to and if we're const
if we have very weird sort of choices we
have to
pick between them and what happens
happen so i wanted to make it easier for
people
to actually break out of their filter
bubble a little bit and see
other points of view right so you're not
actually creating new news
you're changing how people gain access
to news
precisely that is why about a rag tag
band of nerds like myself could actually
do something like this and make it free
because trading news would be super
expensive that would be a journalism
project
here the premise is that there are
actually a lot of interesting news out
there
and a lot of news which are very
misleading
and to create a tool it just makes it
easier for people
to navigate this so first people told me
max
you know this is never going to work
because people are stupid people just
want to be told what they already
believe
but as i said i don't buy that and in
fact there's a really nice
study by a colleague of mine in mit
professor david rand
also suggesting that actually people
like to be
to find out if they're wrong if as long
as it's presented in a respectful way
right if you're planning on doing a
little startup company
wouldn't you like it if some friend
explains to you that this is never going
to work
and explains what you've missed of
course you want to know that right
but if he starts by just insulting you
you're not even going to listen to the
rest
and and in today's media landscape if
you have someone who's only been reading
this particular media source and they
decide to
take a walk on the wild side and go look
at something else and the
first thing they see is like a photo of
their favorite politicians
that's chosen to be deliberately ugly to
illustrate the article
and then there's some really really
strong insulting words
they'll just sort of tune out um so
what what happens instead if you go to
improve the news.org
is you're in the driver's seat you have
these different sliders you can move
around
one of them says nuance on it so if you
don't want to be insulted
just dial up the high nuance and then
if you want to see now what other what
other
people are reading who disagree with you
you can take this left right slider for
example and
move it over a little bit to the other
side and now see on the same topic that
you had chosen to read about
that other parallel universe so to speak
of what people are saying there
if you um there's another slider which
is also important called
the establishment slider so of course
most of the big newspapers
are owned by powerful companies and so
on
who don't want a lot of news saying bad
things about themselves
uh so if you if you if you'd like to see
more criticism
of of the powerful you can play with
that other slider
and it makes it basically very easy for
you to um
explore alternative viewpoints
so i did it i'm i'm actually on improve
the news.org right now
i figured you know what why why just
listen to you about it
i mean you're only the guy that created
it
why why do i got to take your word for
wait so max so what you're saying is you
are an
aggregator in a in a in a
an interface that filters according to
sliders
that's right that's right all right so
now so now is this every single news
source that's out there
is breitbart one of the search places is
is okay so so
uh is totally extreme left-wing
right-wing
propaganda in there is there you know if
if this were
1937 germany would hitler's stuff be in
there and his pamphlets
like is where is there a limit
to the edges of this that you have
selected yeah there are two limits one
is you know this
we just was just a ragtag bunch of folks
we couldn't put everything that's out
there but it has right now
a lot of stuff about a hundred different
newspapers really spanning the
political spectrum the main limit is
it's just english language stuff
uh second there's nothing in there that
advocates violence for example
so if any kind of hit their stuff would
you would not find there you know okay
all right whiteboard is in there uh
whatever you think of them
they they
there there's a there's there's a very
broad spectrum out on the fringes where
there's a
lot of crazy stuff and
and as long as they're not they're
respecting the democratic ideals and so
on they're in there
and the idea of this is very much not to
be some sort of orwellian thing that
tells you what you should read but put
you in the driver's seat instead so
in other words normally when you go out
and seek the news
right what happens is facebook or google
or whatever will remember
all the things you clicked on before and
figure well this is probably what neil
is going to click on
right so you're basically selecting your
news
impulsively through your clicks it's
just like if you selected what you were
going to eat
by just walking through an
all-you-can-eat buffet and always just
picking things up on impulse
i want to try instead to see what
happens if people are giving
given a more deliberative opportunity to
choose
their news diet kind of like when you
plan out
what you're going to buy ahead of time
in the supermarket instead right
and say i want to try i want to read
about these topics a little bit more
of these topics a little bit less i want
to try and look at from this perspective
um put you in charge so i'm on your site
right now
and i have to say one this is
an excellent idea okay it's freaking
brilliant
i spent i spent an hour on it yesterday
yeah it is really
really i mean it's and the reason why
it's so great is because it's so
simplistic
you know um now the second thing i want
to know
max is is this proprietary did you
actually
take these programs and register them
own them so that when we sell this to
every news
organization
we will they will not be able to come in
and just take this technology
because the truth is as the fact is that
this
allows the um the advertising model
to still stay intact but still gives the
reader
some freedom and some agency over the
content
that they're consuming so you know
reputable news
agencies should actually be using
something like this
because it really is a a very good tool
for the reader
oh thank you my goal with this is to
never make one cent on it ever
i know that's supposed to be my goal max
that's what i'm that's what i'm here for
that's why there are no ads that's why
it's free uh mit
is also one of the pioneers of the whole
open source movement we even give away
our courses for free right so for
example with the machine learning tools
we
developed for this for classifying news
they're already open sourced online
if the goal with this is to improve the
news so if other people
take ideas from this and do things which
also improve the news you know
i say you know more power to them wow
that's what the goal is here
all right so but to have make an
improvement
all right so but suppose i choose to
only get my news through this
medium does this create sort of
copyright problems
fortunately not you know there are many
news aggregators out there
and you cannot
if you go to google news for example you
will also see
apple news you'll see the headline and
then the article you can click on it but
now you come to the newspaper itself
so it's them who is actually giving you
the article that they have copyright on
all right we got to take a quick break
but when we come back i want to get in i
want to get in under the hood
of this and what what are the engines
that are driving it
what is the open source that you use and
what did you add to it
and i want to really find out how it
works and whether in fact
there can be some implicit bias even in
this product that presents itself as
unbiased
so when we come back on star talk
we're back star talk we got chuck nice
here hey hey
chuck you're tweeting a chuck nice comic
still thank you sir i guess
i don't plan on changing it very nice
we're talking about
a physicist reading the newspaper
possibly revolutionizing how people
um think about the news that they're
presented
with this product software basically
it's a
on a website and it's called uh next
it's called
improvement and there was improve the
news and i got max tegmark
old-time friend and colleague professor
of physics up at mit so max
this product allows you to to in real
time
with a slider see different news outlets
treat the same topic through whatever
lens they carry with them
so so that's brilliant and
you think you're sure people will
do that that they will have a curiosity
oh i wonder
what they say about this you think
people will do that or will they just
still stay in their own stovepipe
does this give them more tools to not
have to listen to anybody else
because they can lock it into place lock
in i'm
way right wing just move i'm moving my
slider to the right
and i'm gluing it there
and now i'm going pro and that's it
yeah locked in right be careful is this
an unintended possible consequence i try
to be humble about this
so i'll be the first to acknowledge of
course i don't know exactly
how it will play out but i i feel
pretty strongly i feel quite negative
about this um
very patronizing big brother mentality
of saying i
you neil cannot be trusted at all with
your own choices
i'm going to make them all for you and
and
in that case you know i shouldn't even
let you walk on bridges because you
might decide to jump off of it you know
you shouldn't be allowed to do anything
dangerous
but in all fairness dare i even utter
such a sentence to facebook and google
they weren't thinking to themselves we
can't trust you to make the decision
this is the unforeseen byproduct of
their
business model yeah right and so
not that they aren't blameless but it's
not that they they weren't trying to
play big
bro i have a lot of friends at google
and facebook very
idealistic people i think they had not
foreseen that the simple algorithm
trying to maximize people's screen time
would would
create a very such a polarized society
as we have now
so how do you end up choosing the
articles what's what
let's open up the hood and see what kind
of engine is there so how does this work
so i just wrote a bunch of code which
lives in the cloud which doesn't choose
the article is just downloads vacuum
cleans all the articles
from from 100 different newspapers okay
i don't have time to read
5 000 articles every day myself and
figure out what they're about of course
so for that we do some machine learning
to actually go read each article
and classify it now the machine learning
that is used
today in google and facebook and so on
it mainly classifies you it says okay
based on everything you clicked on we
think that you're gonna
the kind of guy who's likely to click on
this article and this article
um and then just add yeah the machine
learning is
there it's sort of big brother
classifying the user and trying to
manipulate
the user into watching as many ads as
possible here
instead the machine learning is
classifying the articles
and giving you the opportunity to affect
your choices
so the way we did this under the hood
was new york times once upon a time paid
humans to read 1.4 million articles
and classify what they were about into
about 600 different categories a huge
huge data set
and then together with a bunch of mit
students we
trained the so-called artificial neural
network
to read through all this and replicate
this human classification and learn just
to be clear a neural network
is a decision tree basically right that
enables
one bit of information to get you to one
place and then branches
depending on what forces are operating
in that spot is that a fair way to
characterize it
it captures the gist of it and these
have gotten better and better
and and our brain is also a neural
network a bunch of neurons connected
together and it turns out that basically
if you have a lot of data
you can train these things to be quite
good at figuring out whether the article
is about golf
or whether it's about immigration or
something else
and that's why we're immigrant golfers
yeah each article can be classified into
many classes so when you go through the
news
you can go click on any topic and you
get all these sub topics and there's
hundreds of them there
so if you're really interested in golf
you
that's how you that's how it works
that's why you only get to see golf
articles then
and then you can see the different spin
the people put on
golf as it were although honestly it's a
lot more fun to look at controversial
topics
like immigration for example and move
the sliders and see
suddenly how differently the same event
gets covered yeah so this is a this is a
form of ai
basically ai has become a bit of a
marketing term people always want to
call something ai if they want to sell
it
you can call it machine learning if you
don't want to sound so
lofty might be or lofty but yeah
what happens is you take
all the text from all these articles and
you put them into your computer and it's
in our case it classifies them in into
what they're about and so on i happen to
know separately that
you are one of the world's experts and
expositors of the multiverse
and so now you got to fess up did this
idea come to you because you spent so
much time in the multiverse
and then you looked at the media
multiverse and you said
let me bring those two together and let
me
is there some cause and effect here on
this maybe there is a little bit because
i
i actually did catch myself complaining
to me and my wife that people seem
of different political stripes seem to
have ended up in parallel universes now
where they don't communicate anymore and
i think that's
very unhealthy look at how different
that is from a science conference right
you go to a science conference and there
are these people who completely disagree
with you who maybe think that your
idea of galaxy information is rubbish or
your interpretation of quantum mechanics
is obviously stupid
and they're still gonna go for drinks
with you and they will respect you as a
human being
even though they don't think you're
wrong right in fact max one of my most
highly uh liked tweets
was a very simple statement i was anyone
who thinks
scientists like agreeing with one
another
has never attended a scientific
conference
it's a very simple point because people
say well scientist is the establishment
and they're only protecting their
cherished ideas
we have the new age model here then
we're being repressed
and it's like and they don't they have
to all agree i say no that's not how it
works
so i'm very i hate to sound like your
father i'm proud of you
for for taking scientific principles and
saying maybe this can spill out into
society
i think there's so much more that can be
done another cause and effect
thing there of course is you know i just
have this obsession always by looking at
the bigger picture and then trying to
take another step back and look at the
still bigger picture so if i find myself
in this country i love getting ever more
dysfunctional i want to look at the
bigger picture and say well why is that
you know
um it's not like the idea of biased
media is new
i mean there's a here in winchester
massachusetts where i live
there's a plaque this is the house of
the first resident of winchester
john converse lived and then it said
underneath and he was thrown in jail for
speaking disrespectfully of the king
you know do you think he had great free
speech then
of course not the i'm sure the king had
some pretty good bias and spin going on
the newspapers there and
and what so what's new
there's always been people's incentive
powerful people's
incentive to spin things their own way
what's new is exactly the machine
learning stuff
right that's what's happened in recent
years where
suddenly technology has greatly
amplified the ability to create filter
bubbles and probably okay so all you're
doing
so yeah so my idea was just okay let's
take the same technology
and use it for good because tech isn't
evil all right you can use the
technology of a knife
to do bad things but also to make an
awesome barbecue right same with machine
learning
let the machine learning work for the
individual to see through
the biasing attempts rather than leave
it only to
big corporations you know to manipulate
you have you tested whether users
do slide the bar to see the same new
story covered multiple ways have you
done some tests yeah not so much yet but
i'm
i'm very very interested in like it's
brand new right this thing
it's yeah it's brand new development so
the most important thing
actually for anyone who wants to try
this is after you've messed with a bit
go to the
feedback form and send in suggestions
for how to make it better because i have
a lot of ideas and suggestions for
taking other ideas from science
scientific truth finding and
building it on top of this and i'm
actually very curious you you confessed
neil which i was very honored to hear
that you had actually wasted a lot of
time yesterday
playing with it what did you do
what was your reaction yeah yeah so no
it was like oh my gosh
um because i like because
as an educator i need i want to know i
need to know
how people are thinking otherwise i ca i
have no access points
to their to what's going on in their
brain so
i i i don't say that i relish in it but
i see it as an
obligation as a public educator
to know what you're being fed in all
parts of the political spectrum
then when i come to you and have a
conversation i'll have some insights
into where you came from and what what
what forms of bias you might be carrying
and a sensitivity like you said
you don't call someone an idiot you just
you you offer
ways they might be wrong but in a polite
way and generally
it's hard for them to be angry back at
you if you come to them in a polite way
but we're all polarized
and everyone digs their heels in deeper
when the fight begins
and nothing nobody gets anywhere so i
just spent time picking stories and
oh that's it and i just just sliding
back and forth
that's all i did for like a half hour so
so so the thing that strikes me here
is the fact that um i am looking at
two men who are brilliant scientists
and that uh most likely
will uh say that there there are there
is such a thing as an objective truth
okay um what do you do with the person
who comes to this place and
they are just steeped in their own
confirmation bias
and the only thing they're looking to do
is reinforce that
first of all i think it's very important
to go in with humility
and be honest about the fact that even
though many people think
that we scientists prove things and know
the absolute truth
that's our dirty little secret we never
prove anything in science we just
disprove things right we've spent
hundreds of years thinking newton's
gravity was the [ __ ]
and then we realized oh it's not the
[ __ ] it's a little bit wrong in fact
very wrong
when you get near black hole just to be
clear the [ __ ] was used in a good
context there
right yeah yes you're not [ __ ]
no it wasn't just [ __ ] yeah well no
clearly clearly max knows a couple of
black people because
le that's that's black people talk
that's yeah it's like yo i'm the [ __ ]
but go ahead going with some humility
and actually i think a lot of the fact
checking that we're seeing now in the
media which is causing a lot of
controversy
i think much of it comes the idea comes
from a good place to
create more truth but it's it's done in
a very sloppy way which
which sort of uh is not it's not at all
as careful as what we do in science
because in science if it were so easy to
figure out the truth
right that some committee for some
company
could just easily figure it out we could
close science we would be done
right the whole reason we still have
science is because it's so hard to
figure out the truth
and sometimes we go for a long time with
almost all scientists thinking oh
this is the correct theory of gravity
just later on to get
be like oopsie we were kind of wrong
about that
so so when someone comes to me and says
i don't believe what you're saying
the first thing i think i want to do is
be humble and say of course i don't know
for a fact either
but then we can make it into more of a
joint exploration okay so
let's look at the facts then look at the
evidence together you know
both none of us going into it with the
axiom that the other one is wrong and
idiot
right now it's a joint search for
truth which is a much more healthy
perspective i think and it starts with
what you said
neil with trying to understand also
where where the other person is
you know i would never go to a country
i've never been to before
without googling them a little bit first
finding out a bit about their traditions
and how they think about things over
there
otherwise what kind of what kind of
american are you
you gotta go there and say how come you
not do what americans do yeah
and speak english we're gonna talk to
someone who
believes very differently the first
thing i also want to do is just
understand as neil said so
beautifully there like what is their
world what is it they've been told
so so all right so let's let's um
establish a landscape here so a person
comes up to the app
and they represent one extreme on the
spectrum let's say because if in the
middle they don't really need the app
right it's really the people who are
warring factions
on opposite sides of a spectrum all
right can i actually interject there
i think we people we meaning that people
like
the three like the three of us who hang
out a lot in our
sort of intellectual university centered
bubbles
we can sometimes be a little bit
arrogant and and say assume that the
problem is not at all
us it's just that all those fringe
people are wrong
but we have the complete truth i
actually find it
quite humbling to think about that many
of
my very smartest colleagues have also
been very wrong about things like when
when the iraq war the second one was
about to happen
most of my colleagues were quite
convinced that there were weapons of
mass destruction in iraq
they believed it and they had read it in
the new york times
right and and yet
we now know that that was just not
correct right so
i think nobody should assume that the
problem is only with other people
well no i'm so let me just for me the
problem
is not so much what the world looks like
through your lens the problem is what
the point you raised at the beginning
yeah you feel so strongly about it that
you are almost militarized in your
attitudes
regarding it and so my only point here
is you
um if we look at the two ends of
the spectrum my question would be if i
am
one end of it will i be motivated to
look at
what others are saying on the other end
yeah and
the hope here the goal and it's in its
infancy so i'd be delighted to see how
this
comes along is will people at least
realize yeah that there are other
perspectives out there
yeah and maybe go out and have a beer
and talk about those perspectives i
certainly hope so
einstein has this great quote that i put
right that
the greatest enemy of truth is blind
belief and authority
right so if you talk to someone who has
a very strong
belief about something it's interesting
to ask what authority is it that they
believe in blindly
and then start poking about that a
little bit that's good that's good
okay so with that what about identity
so what you just said there where if you
have a very strong belief in authority
if that authority
has now grafted itself as a part of your
identity
for me to believe differently i now must
deny
my own identity that's the cult problem
that's that's how you it's why it's so
hard to get out of a cult that's
very deep and and i s we've seen that in
science also right if
we must never get too so emotionally
attached to
our own scientific theories that we make
them part of our identity
it's like i am a flat earth guy or i am
a
geocentrist or whatever because then we
start to become poor scientists
once you start labeling labeling what
you are then that boxes you in
that's exactly right max exactly my wife
maya likes to say we should keep our
identity
small which i think is very profound we
should
we should not make it part of our make
our
beliefs about all sorts of facts part of
our identity
let it be a flowing river that can move
where it needs to in the face of
evidence that emerges
that's when you're a good scientist and
and this thing about einstein saying we
should always question authority you
know feynman also used to stress that as
being the core of being a scientist that
everything it has to be open for
questioning the ultimate
authority to have the question of course
is our own prejudices
and you look now at some of the greatest
breakthroughs in science like einstein
for instance
what was it that he did better than
everybody else
it wasn't that the math for example of
special relativity was
so hard that no one else could do it but
he was the first person to just
challenge this prejudice that everybody
had
the time flows at the same rate for
everybody you know once you started
questioning it it started unraveling and
before long there you had it special
relativity theory right
so if einstein had access to your app
he'd be even better
so max this is where we part uh our
third segment we're going to sort of
bring in a
journalism specialist to just think
about and analyze
what effect this might have on the
landscape going forward was been a
delight to have you on and this is just
another chapter of the many chapters
that occupy
your very active uh and fascinating
brain
uh that we had the privilege to tap for
star talk so thanks for being on
uh chuck you're gonna hang around we've
got another segment coming
this is star talk the physicist reads
the newspaper we'll be right back
we're back star talk segment three
of improving the news we're coming off
of two segments with my friend and
colleague
max tegmark where he had told us about
a new app that he wrote in fact that we
interacted with it on the website
uh improvethenews.org and it's an
ai powered news aggregator where you can
just slide what how
conservative or liberal you want your
news to be i just thought that was a
fascinating
take on what it is to aggregate news
and so and and chuck you and i don't
have particular expertise in this but we
know someone who does
jeff jarvis a friend of star talk you've
been on multiple times
jeff great to have you back i miss you
guys
oh yeah so you're professor of
journalism at the city university of new
york
your director of the tau knight center
for entrepreneurial journalism
nice at the craig newmark school for
journalism
so oh wait it keeps going okay you're
the leonardo
that's enough okay
[Laughter]
now i have no time left to talk
you're you you have a named
professorship so that
that t-o-w in the tao night
you're the leonard tao professor of
journalism gotta
give give a shout out to those who endow
these chairs
and you have a blog buzzmachine.com
and author from a few years ago let me
read this here geeks
bearing gifts imagining new futures for
news well the world has changed quite a
bit even since that book came out
in 2014. so say welcome back to star
talk i just want to get your
your take on max's new tool have you had
have you had a chance to check it out
yeah i've had i've had time to play with
it it's very cool i have two concerns
but then i'm going to be very
complimentary
the first concern is i think that we in
news have too often put people into
binary buckets right
left right white black 99 one percent
four against
and so i'm cautious about about things
that that
lack the nuance that is possible online
for us to be
in many different communities so jeff in
that in that 99
1 we could have the 83 17 percent
and the 64 36 percent and that's nuanced
right
it is it is well but then that leads to
the second problem i have
which is that basically there's i'll say
this
next to no responsible uh conservative
media in the u.s
we have one major outlet which is fox
news which believe it or not and gallup
is seen as the most trusted
outlet in news why because there's one
of them and then all the rest of us are
liberal
and i'm liberal and i think we have a
lack of
a decent conservative media i actually
believe as a liberal media person that
we should invest more in conservative
media
to provide competition to fox so the
problem with the app there is it has
very little to call upon that's
responsible before it gets to oan
on the right wow
oh wow so all it has is what's out there
and you're and so you you're not blaming
the app you're blaming the world
exactly that's really what you're
blaming okay okay okay
you're on the road wouldn't that be a
reflection uh
jeff of who we are as consumers i mean
is it isn't this kind of an outworking
or maybe it's
like two mirrors facing one another
where the outworking
is this is what i want so this is what
they do
which makes me want it which makes them
do it which makes me want more
so you understand yeah it's okay it's a
good question chuck and and it's an
unanswerable one because of the chicken
and egg question
as to which came first uh the market
that created it or the demand for that
market
i i think in this chicken egg problem
does does have an answer and i'll tell
you that
i'm just saying i'm just saying it was
the egg that came
first uh it was just laid by a bird that
was not a chicken
so boy was that mother surprised yes
and then you get the mutation that gets
you the new bird which we call a chicken
but but no but i want to finish your
comments on the on the improve the news
go so so
but i do think there's something really
important here which is in my view the
internet so far has been built to speak
and i celebrate that because we can
finally hear black lives matter and me
too and living well black and all these
things that were not
represented in mainstream mass media run
by people who look like me
old white men so that's i celebrate that
speech immensely yes that also brings
with us q
online it's worth the price in my mind
but the internet i want to see next the
next phase of it
is an internet that's built to listen
and to tell us what and who are worth
listening to
that's where mac's app really impresses
me because i think it starts to go to a
next generation of the net
where it says all right there's all this
stuff out there some of it's good some
of it's bad
uh some of it looks in the world this
way someone the world looks that way and
i can help you
find those things to give you a picture
of the world so so back to your question
chuck
in a sense what max does when you go to
the right on his slider
is you get an anthropological view of
what my father and my uncle are seeing
now
right on fox news and such uh it's
worthwhile to that extent
but i don't think it's what we want to
have as a picture of a
of a of a world it's not an accurate
picture of the world gotcha
so okay well wait wait wait wait no no
wait wait wait if chuck to chuck's point
if you they give you what you want and
then you want what they give you
what do you mean it's not accurate it is
accurate if that's what people want and
that's what we're being given
what's how accurate about that i grew up
right
i grew up in a time where i the only
choice i had was to watch uh gilligan's
island and kids today may think that was
fun but i can tell you it was hell
it was the only choices we were given
right and so
the mass market that whole light well
the internet kills
is the mass market business model mass
media and with it this idea of the mass
this idea that there is one public and
one view of the world
that again walter cronkite one walter
chris walter cronkite
god bless him god rest him but that was
bs that's the way the world was it was
the way the world was for a certain
number of people who had power
right okay so it's a democratization of
news
yes i think that what's really happening
today what i celebrate
is the fact that we can all speak i'm
researching a book on the gutenberg era
and the end of it
as i go back to the early days of print
i saw that that that print was very
conversational martin luther conversed
through print with popes
erasmus with thomas moore and so on we
lost that conversation somewhere along
along the line probably with steam power
and mass
scale and mass media and i think what's
happening today is that we are
re-learning as a society
how to hold a conversation with
ourselves interesting
so let me ask you this then um
how do we decipher
between those who responsibly
report and those who willingly
obuscate for the purposes of profit i
was watching
how somebody's supposed to know if they
don't if they're not you jeff how are
they supposed to know
that is difficult but that's where i
think we have the opportunity to create
new services
i have a project going on now at the
school which is trying to define
quality and news i also think it's
responsible for us in news to start
cleaning our house
we say to facebook and twitter clean
your house well we haven't cleaned our
own we journalists haven't stood up and
said what we really think about fox news
and rupert murdoch and it's time that we
do something
interesting well what about filter
bubbles then because we find ourselves
in a bubble we don't even know it
actually actually professor uh the
filter bubble is more of a myth
than anything else there's a wonderful
book i'll recommend by axel bruns who's
a uh
an academic in australia called are
filter bubbles real
his answer no no tons of research
says short book okay well it's well
well condensed um
the research so just so we clear i'm
just on the same page
a filter bubble is what we think it is
where
you you're only reinforced with the
information you want to believe is true
and you don't know anything outside the
bubble is that a fair characterization
yes so what axel bruns does in his book
is he goes through a lot of research
that says the filter bubble theory it
was a theory
uh is not borne out by how google treats
us google doesn't give us different
googles for everybody else
it's not borne out by our social
behavior most people actually don't get
rid of uncle joe who's miserable and
rotten because he's still uncle joe
and we still hear uncle joe's opinions
and we're aware of them
and so the filter bubble and the echo
chamber don't really rule us and the
problem becomes
when we start to make those assumptions
oh my god everybody's in a filter bubble
or everybody doesn't know how media work
we invent
interventions that are not necessarily
appropriate josh tucker who is a
researcher at new york university did
some great research
where he looked at disinformation and
said who's spreading this
and is it our kids as we fear so we
let's have let's have
um media literacy for them
no it's grandpa who's screwing up the
world it's
old men who again look like me who were
spreading the disinformation in the
world
and my daughter told me exactly that
she's 23. she said you guys are messing
up the world not us
and i said that she's right she's right
damn right so what how did things get so
polarized i don't
i remembered yes you had warring
factions of course that's not new
in politics it just feels worse today so
what caused that i think there's two
answers you guys caused it
media oh yeah that's that's the first
answer is we did it we put everybody
into binary buckets and set them at war
with each other
we are built in our business model for
attention and conflict
not for cooperation and collaboration
but the second issue is
i think we go back to the myth of walter
cronkite it was only from the 50s
until about the end of the century where
we had this idea of of mass media and
everybody watching the same thing before
that going back to the beginning of
newspapers in 1605
they represented many different
viewpoints many different perspectives
it was only when tv you guys
killed the newspapers that we got to
this idea of the monopoly having to
serve everybody
and we get then to very interestingly
here is the myth of objectivity
right so this idea of objectivity is
that there's one view of the world
a wesley lowry a former washington post
reporter and pulitzer prize winner wrote
an op-ed in the new york times a few
months ago
where he said objectivity is actually a
construct
of white racism in newsrooms because it
is one more time
people who look like me old white men
who have the power who decide what is
objective and what is biased
and and so this idea that there was one
view of the world from walter cronkite
that was the same for everybody that
served everybody equally
was always a myth wow
wow okay so what you're okay you're
bumming me out here so what you're
saying i know
there's no no you are no no so what
you're saying is
there is no such let's imagine if
if you will a newspaper where the first
half
is objectively verifiable information
about the world and then the second half
splits
into how do you think about this
objectively true
information mr and mrs liberal person
and mr and mrs conservative person and
then
you get outlooks on what is factually
agreeable
is that not possible i thought that was
the new york times oh my god i'm so
deceived
now i will depress you i don't think
facts are enough
i don't think fact-checking is enough uh
dana boyd who's a brilliant researcher
in new york at data and society
says that we are in an epistological war
if i don't like you
i don't like your experts they're elite
like you and i don't like your facts so
i'm just going to say
things that peeve you for the sake of
peeving you
that's where we are we're in an
epistemological war where perhaps what
we need is not so much more education
in facts but more education in each
other how do we become more
sympathetic empathetic understanding
knowledgeable
any of those about our fellow citizen
situations how do we find common
uh cause there you know i don't believe
i i reread uh hannah iran's uh
uh origins of totalitarian recently
totalitarianism recently
chuck just read that too he was telling
yeah
at the coffee lounge it's yeah it's it's
so she said that um in totalitarian
regimes
people tend to give up their everyday
concerns for abstract concepts right so
think about america right now i don't
believe that half of america thinks that
guns and abortion are the single most
important thing their lives every day
no what's most important in their lives
is the welfare and safety of their
families
that i share with them you share with
them we all share that
but media come in and pres my business
and we present the world as if it's in
conflict about these abstract notions
and that's how the agenda of the
discussion gets set and it's not very
productive
are you saying that if we were to take
what is
uh you know the venn diagram of america
and we were to create more intersections
where people
have overlapping identities or the
recognition
of where their identities overlap that
that acknowledgement alone would do
more to bring us together than trying to
convince somebody
about a particular stance on an issue
neil would you would nominate that man
for a pulitzer prize or perhaps a nobel
peace prize i think actually
uh yes yes chuck exactly i think that's
what we need we need to make strangers
less strange
we need to take away that power of the
other we need to understand that we
share
more interest than we don't and media
haven't done that i don't think they
give us a very accurate view of the
world as a result
interesting now see as a comedian i hate
everybody
so now but everybody loves you that's
how it works
okay you got me
all right so but suppose i have what i
think of as a trusted source that i
always go to
don't people need a trusted source and
it's yes it's a problem that people have
different trusted sources
but are you trying to abandon the entire
concept
of the go-to place to get the
information upon which you base your
world view
no but i'm saying it's place ends it's
plural
and that's why the app is good because
the app does expose you to other
perspectives and other ways to see
things
the problem is some are good some are
bad and your definition of good and my
definition of good
are going to vary but that's okay
because that's what a democracy is
you know i've really seen through my
study about the early days of print
that that society is a conversation and
that what we have to do in media
is to serve that conversation to make
that conversation better
yes more informed but also more
respectful as chuck said
and also productive so we can get
somewhere and actually solve problems
if someone is a particularly
vociferous racist you can't tell me i
just have to think more about where
they're coming from
and then i will understand their
position there's certain
non-starters in a conversation
absolutely what does one do about that
but i think what you do in that
situation so the new york times tries to
do this where they did they did a
feature
about a year ago on here's a racist he
goes to panera just like you and me and
he wears khaki pants
right that normalizes that person that's
no good
that's what we have to do is understand
their circumstances
right we've got to understand where they
come from so we can then see what to do
now i wonder neil is whether journalism
should look more like education
look more like your fields where should
we say
here's a goal the goal is people should
wear masks
and they should get vaccinations and
they should trust science
and if they don't we've failed now does
that make me an advocate
i'm fine with that because you're an
advocate for science and so should we be
well here's another thing in science if
i'm in a debate with you
about something not entirely fully
known in the universe one of three
things
is true either i'm right and you're
wrong
you're right and i'm wrong or we're both
wrong but we can't both be right
and we both go into that conversation
knowing and understanding those three
possible outcomes
and in almost every case it's we need
more data
right so that we can then agree who is
right
and awesome and well we can still go out
for a beer after
we're not canceling each other the the
difference is and we're not from my
observation watching you guys debate one
another is
that you almost want
your guy who to who's on the opposite
side to be
right if he can show you that you're
wrong you're like
cool you showed me i'm wrong now we can
move on to the next thing
whereas right now that's a culture
that's a culture
right but but but the way things are now
if you show me that i'm wrong i dig in
further and now you're a greater threat
and now you have to die you know
which is why which is why we need both
science
and humanities both are key we need
education the answer to this is not one
course one new app one different kind of
news the answer to this as always
damn it is education wow nice
jeff always good to have you on we don't
have you on enough i think
i agree with that see we're both right
here i agree with you
so so you tweeting what what's your
social media platforms here before
twitter jeff jarvis medium
jeffjarvis.medium.com
excellent excellent so we can look for
you and track your stuff and you're
working on a book maybe when the book
comes out
you come here first and we'll talk about
it i hope before so it's still taking a
while but yes i'll come there okay we'll
be we'll be
we hope to be around right along with
you all right chuck always good to have
you on star talk
always a pleasure i'm neil degrasse
tyson your personal astrophysicist
of course
[Music]
you